Nazism arrived via democratic channels
and it is because we let certain ideas spread,
because we did not know how to denounce this evil,
that it went on to become absolute evil.
I was brought up by parents who regretted
the failure of a European project,
a first project - that of Briand and Stresemann.
I often thought that,
had Briand and Stresemann been listened to,
I would never have found myself in Auschwitz.
For me the only hope was Europe, reconciliation.
I wished for this reconciliation,
because I felt deeply that so much hatred,
so much barbarity, could only lead to a third world war.
European construction remains the most important event
of the past 50 years.
It's Europe that has changed our destiny,
our hope and confidence for the future.
We cannot have any tolerance
towards those who express ideas of exclusion,
of racism and xenophobia.
This should be the role of all educators, at all levels.
It is also incumbent upon historians,
because I do not believe that we have learned from history,
from what history has taught us.
There were things, written in logic,
that we didn't want to see between 1933 and 1940.
By the time we took them seriously it was too late,
but we knew all along.
That's the lesson,
the lesson for history and for Europe is to keep building.
I think the European Parliament is already considering
whether the European Union should have its own legal framework,
a symbolic declaration of human rights
at the heart of the EU.
It could be a model and an example.
Thank you.